Casting on for 2x2 ribbing
following most knitting machine manuals
can be a bit confusing,
even if you're able to translate
and follow the instructions, remembering
all the steps can be a challenge.
Let's walk through the steps for this cast
on and try to understand what's going on.
This plus a cheat sheet is
going to go a long way.
Now, 2x2, ribbing is basic,
there are 2 needles on the main bed,
2 needles and the ribber
alternating across the row.
Now, for this caston, you need to make
sure that the END needles are on the main bed
add a couple of extra needles from your
instructed cast on number if you need to.
Here's the secret. We're going to be using
two different Ribber positions
for this ribber set up.
The first position is
your knitting position.
The Ribber set to P full pitch and the
racking handle is set to position 5.
So the needles are directly
across from each other.
Now, this is what your Ribber is going
to look like when you're
doing the actual knitting.
The other position is the caston position.
You'll set your Ribber to H or half
pitch temporarily and you'll rack by one
number during the cast on only.
So let's take a look, I've set my machine
to the knitting position. Again,
the needles are straight
across from each other.
The needles are on the main bed.
I thread up my machine and I knit across.
There's no way to hang a cast
on comb, I immediately can
tell that I forgot something.
And that is setting the ribber
to the cast on position.
When I set the machine to pitch H
and rack from 5 to 4,
then knit cross,
you'll see the strands going across
the opening between the beds.
You'll use these strands
to hang your cast on comb.
Now, these strands are going to be
the very bottom edge of our ribbing,
so they need to be knitted tightly.
Remember, they're going
to be stretched by the comb.
So if possible, you'll want to knit this
zigzag row at tension zero on both beds.
For a heavier yarn
you may not be able to use tension zero,
but knit as tightly as
you can for a nice edge.
On Brother machines,
it's recommended to use the "two for tiny"
setting on the Ribber carriage.
This will tighten the zigzag
row considerably.
Look closely, here's another uh oh.
Because you shifted the needles
to the right for the cast on,
you need to pull up one needle
on the ribber just one little needle
when you knit that zigzag row.
You'll cast on this extra stitch.
But we're going to take
care of that in a minute.
OK, to review, you've selected your two
by two, needle set up, casting
on the appropriate number of needles.
Now, set the machine to your cast on set
up. Rack from 5 to 4 and swing
the Ribber to pitch H. You're now
set up in the cast on position.
Pull that one little lonesome needle
into working position,
thread up your carriage,
set both carriages to knit as tightly as
possible and knit across. And your
bed should look like this.
Hang your Ribber comb.
Now for a perfect selvedge,
set your machine to knit on the main bed,
only. The ribber needles should not knit.
Knit across.
You'll be going from left to right.
Next, set your machine to knit on the ribber
only and from right to left.
So you have stitches on the main
bed and stitches on the ribber bed.
Now, set your machine to knit only
on the main bed and knit to the right one more
time. Again, only the main
bed needles are going to knit.
This completes your cast on.
Now we want to return the ribber
to the main knitting position or your
knitting position.
That means swing the Ribber to P or
full pitch and rack back to 5.
Now it's time to retire that one little
extra stitch.
you'll transfer it up from the Ribber
to the main bed,
doubling up the needle on the left,
on the main bed.
And we're done with a cast
on position of the ribber.
Your needles are going to be opposite each
other and you're going
to continue knitting.
But wait, wait, wait,
don't start knitting yet.
Remember we said everything for a really
tight cast on. Loosen up that tension.
Following your pattern,
you may knit your ribbing one or two
numbers tighter than your garment,
but you certainly aren't
going to knit it at zero.
There are so many things
to remember with this technique.
Make yourself a cheat sheet,
my ribber manual isn't really clear.
I always seem to forget a step every time
I try to knit 2x2 ribbing
and the checklist really helps.
And with all that being said,
there really is a better way.
How would you like a method where there's
no racking, no swinging,
no muss, no fuss?
Check out the easiest, best Ribber Caston
in the Knit it Now Learning Library.
Thank you for watching and happy knitting.